let's go to the audience via Discord
davidpackman.com Discord and here what
is on the minds of the people the minds
of the people we will go first I hope
I'm pronouncing this correctly to Tressa
of Minnesota is that correct Tressa
well I pronounce it Teresa can you hear
me Teresa welcome yes
great
listen I'm from Minnesota as you know we
are a blue state I'm a Democrat I'm
Progressive I'm liberal
I like to say that I will vote for Joe
Biden even if he is slumped over in a
wheelchair drooling because the GOP is
that dangerous
um
we know that the GOP big part of their
platform
um so far has been big heavy anti-trans
um transgender you know they don't even
want them to exist and they pull in a
lot of suburban women when they hear
about children you know
children are being mutilated blah blah
blah which is not even true but you know
the response from the left seems to be
um dismissive oh they make up a such a
small minority of you know Democrat
percentage of the demographic of the
population it's not even worth talking
about
and I kind of disagree and I have two
points that I would like to talk about
number one
I don't know what it's like in other
states but like I said I live in
Minnesota liberal state
and
corporations and companies and
um you know board meetings and park
boards and City Council meetings and
knitting groups
all start off their meetings by asking
people what their names are and to
declare your preferred pronoun I mean
this is there's not even a transgender
person in the room there might not be a
transgender person in a 10-mile radius
and it seems overboard just like the GOP
goes overboard I think sometimes the
left goes overboard I think the
intentions are good you know they want
to be inclusive and accepting but
asking someone what their pronouns are
is kind of intrusive I think so let me
address this Teresa because you've said
a lot and I don't want to forget all the
different points you made so first of
all from a very tactical level my
opinion is I'm also against the
unprovoked
putting forward of pronouns as a matter
of core of of sort of standard operating
procedure I know a number of teachers
who teach in schools where they started
the year doing that and then they very
quickly figured out hey you know what
this actually isn't great number one
it's not great because the truth is
trans people are a very small part of
the population and so the why is it that
we are doing this absent any particular
reason to do it now one reason would be
well you're making everyone in the room
comfortable because by by having
everyone State their pronouns someone
who has pronouns that might not be
obvious from their physical appearance
will be more comfortable the
Counterpoint to that Teresa is there
might be people in the group in the
audience in the room whatever who are
currently struggling with gender
identity who actually don't want to be
in the position to have to State here
are my pronouns so I would call it like
it it Nets out to zero but my general
view is I don't think that that's
something we need to be doing I'm very
comfortable as a trans empathetic and
supportive individual
basically taking my best guess at what
people's pronouns are which by the way
when you're talking to the person rarely
even comes up it's usually when
referring to the person to some other
person but anyway and if I get it wrong
it's very obvious that I'm not doing it
in bad faith and someone can correct me
and whatever so that's my view on the
statement of pronouns piece does that
make sense to you
yes yes triple yes okay yes to all of
that yes to all of that on the earlier
thing you said Teresa which was along
the lines of
there may be it may not be the best
approach to just say this isn't even a
big enough issue to talk about and
dismissing it outright you're you're not
big on that I think I understood is that
right
correct my thought on this is sort of as
follows
we should recognize that
it is no longer acceptable
to treat or
um stereotype
that many groups that at one point was
okay to do like there was a point in the
United States where it was just totally
acceptable to use the n-word when
referring to black black people separate
sinks bathrooms water fountains and
restaurants okay that's changed it's no
longer acceptable to do that there was a
point at which using the f word for gay
people was acceptable and you could
openly discriminate that's not
acceptable so what what's happening is
that
Ace the the right is
going to smaller and smaller groups in
order to find someone that maybe they
can get away with scapegoating and I do
think it's important to recognize that
we shouldn't overstate the prevalence of
trans people because like this happens
with anti-semites Theresa if you ask
some anti-semites listen what percentage
of the population do you think is even
Jewish and sometimes they'll say five
ten twenty percent and you go you know
it's point two percent right so I do
think it's good
to be accurate about the size of a
population
at the same time I agree with you that
just saying it's not an issue because it
isn't a big population it's not a very
that's not a super strong defense I
agree with you
yeah I don't think that it's a small
issue because when people are being
harmed it's an issue right you know
um companies whatever can have their uh
diversity and inclusion policies I don't
know most companies have a hand book or
whatever make it very clear that there
are consequences than ramifications for
p treating people disrespectfully by not
calling them by the name that they wish
to be called by whether you think that
name belongs to what they look like or
not sure you know yeah so it's not
ignoring it but not going overboard the
other way which I think alienates a lot
of people Theresa and I I mostly agree
with everything you're saying I know you
had more but I have so many people
waiting and we've been on almost 10
minutes I want to keep getting people on
if that's okay okay okay thank you all
right Theresa from Minnesota very
powerful stuff here is the the perfect
Father's Day gift get him a Wi-Fi
connected digital picture frame from
Aura our sponsor Aura has been named the
number one best digital picture frame by
wire cutter the strategist and wired
this is not one of these early 2000s
picture frames there's no USB or SD
cards and you get free unlimited storage
and you can instantly frame photos and
videos from any device anywhere in the
world I have several of these I got my
dad one and so now I take pictures of
the baby load them into his or a frame
and they show up and everybody loves it
you know it's no more of these having to
bring a slideshow When I visit I just
put the pictures right in the frame I'm
really glad I got him one of these and
right now Aura has a great deal for
Father's Day go to auraframes.com Pacman
use the code Pacman to get 30 30 dollars
off plus free shipping this deal ends
June 18th so don't wait terms and
conditions apply the link is down below